what like seriously like you people that
are good at yoga god bless you my name
is Paula Gelbart I'm a physical
therapist and a yoga teacher say I
normally teach adults I normally teach
adults and yoga teachers I think it's
gonna go well today have you ever done
yoga before no never it'd be like not
like hardcore like yoga oh right like
mom mom yoga but I've done like
handstands is that that conditioning we
go I'd make me feel like free are you
ready to try yoga today oh so we start
with our feet together at the front of
the mat lift your arms up overhead raise
your arms up high and then fold forward
all the way down try to touch your toes
up and step into plank you do this push
yourself up and back good oh I'm not
relaxing at all no and down I'm okay
dad are you gonna say grounding dog dog
her rounded shake your tail yeah step
your feet forward and reach up take your
hands up take your hands down into your
heart that was a Sun Salutation Sun
Salutation aim that's anyone really like
warming up my body
oh like you're doing it to heaven and
like it's a new one for me my mom after
the trauma if you hold your nose while
standing on one foot it makes you
balance better all right now stand with
your feet together and bend your right
knee out to the side other leg grab your
right foot uh-huh
put your right foot on your left thigh
reach your arms up and grow your tree
my tree sways a lot yeah there's a lot
of wind over there right my injuries
yeah well as well you'll it'll get cut
trees have a hard life I guess one thing
those people that are good at Yoga don't
wear jeans and I'm learning that the
hard way let me tell me yoga was really
fun and hard I'm upside down like woah
feels like I'm in another dimension I
think it was challenging to definitely
the pretzel I would give you a warning
not to do this unless you really want to
feel like your foots coming off your
body I was I had some warrants but I
haven't expression yoga is pretty much
conditioning and it like gets you
encouraged to be more flexible
every second is like mayham so like
seriously like god bless those people
like you and like Kaylee who are good at
this so-called sport Tory would you work
with me again yeah I thought you were
really good you're like like really good
she said never give up and I like that
when I got it she said great when I
didn't she said try again you know what
that's what a great teacher does so I
learned that kids are unstoppable do you
want me to spot you
no you can just cut it oh Jesus can you
bend your knees and touch your head with
your feet yeah good job gonna can you do
that no I can't do that